[Musique]
c'est
durant l'été retour sur les rencontres
avec les entrepreneurs saint quentinois
de cette saison de l'industrie à
l'artisanat en passant par la recherche
et le développement
le sky échos racontent la vie des
acteurs économiques du territoire
l'occasion aussi de découvrir les
activités économiques et les innovations
produite à saint quentin en yvelines
le chantier a débuté en juin 2010 9 le
bâtiment native a été conçu par le
promoteur immobilier codic avec comme
locataire le groupe orange une
infrastructure de dix neuf mille mètres
carrés avec huit étages pour en parler
nous sommes avec yann le gall le
directeur général adjoint de comics
france bonjour bonjour nicolas
alors où en étant dans ce chantier eh
bien écoutez on est dans le run final à
savoir que nous devons livrer cette
opération dans six mois à orange donc le
principal locataire de l'opération et
hsbc qui l'a acheté pour le compte de ça
et ces pays elise et pierre alors
quelles sont les caractéristiques de ce
bâtiment écoutez c'est le dernier né de
codic france donc c'est une opération je
dirais up to day they qui intègre tous
les besoins essentiels des utilisateurs
et d'ailleurs elle a été plébiscitée par
un grand utilisateur de la région ile de
france qui est le groupe orange vous
l'avez dit l'idée c'est de pouvoir
permettre à orange d'adapter ses modes
de travail et de pouvoir travailler
notamment tout ce qui est en mode projet
voilà et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup de l'obsolescence du parc
tertiaire alors avant on en parlait
plutôt sous l'angle de la performance
énergétique et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
l'enjeu qui nous anime c'est de pouvoir
permettre les nouveaux usages et pour ce
faire on adapte la technique de nos
bâtiments et notamment par exemple tout
ce qui est le renouvellement d'air
[Musique]
nous avons rejoint isabelle marie
directrice des projets stratégiques chez
jc decaux bonjour bonjour
alors avec vous on va parcourir
l'histoire du groupe à travers ces
mobiliers urbains alors déjà comment ont
évolué et mobilier urbain jc decaux
alors ils vont évidemment évolué même si
et vous envoyer plein d'exemples ici
autour de vous sur ce parc expo du
campus de de plaisir
l'abribus c'est vraiment un des services
les plus développés en france et dans le
monde par jc decaux et c'est avant tout
un service donc un service qui a
profondément changé depuis 1964 la
mobilité dans les villes donc
aujourd'hui par exemple en france on a
plus 3000 collectivités locales parmi
nos partenaires et ce mobilier bien sûr
il sert à attendre le bus
confortablement
il a un design qui est spécifique et
très particulier c'est une des valeurs
cardinales chez jc decaux que de
travailler ce design et il accueille des
fonctions alors au fil du temps il a
accueilli des fonctions par exemple
d'information voyageurs très important
aux mobilités et petit à petit en fait
il s'est enrichi d'autres services je
vous donne un exemple des prises usb
quand on est à court de batterie on peut
se brancher sous un abribus et passer
son passé son coup de fil est alors au
delà du mobilier urbain jc decaux vous
êtes aussi présent dans les usages en
termes de mobilité douce un oui tout à
fait et sur les mobilités douces et en
particulier le vélo en libre service
c'est une activité que nous avons
développée dès 2003 à vienne puis étendu
en france donc aujourd'hui par exemple
en france on opère dans 43 collectivités
locales et le taux de satisfaction
global de nos systèmes qui est vraiment
plébiscité par les utilisateurs et de
92% donc ça répond à une attente très
forte dans les centres urbains ont une
attente des collectivités locales comme
des citoyens
pour une mobilité plus partagés plus
douce merci isabelle marie je vous en
prie
[Musique]
la première étape est la réception de
dijon reçoit des affiches imprimées sur
du papier fsc issu de forêts gérées
durablement ensuite on va la première
étape ça va être la réception des photos
qui va être ensuite complètement
informatisé on va rentrer notre système
et ensuite on va préparer l'ensemble des
affiches vous voyez ici comme ça on va
si on va aller colisée sa deuxième étape
on va faire du colisage on va leur
rouler pour ensuite comme vous allez le
voir sur les images et derrière faire
des colis pour chaque affichage chaque
affichage va recevoir ses actifs
identifiés pour lui même si aujourd'hui
on prépare un cent mille affiches par
semaine seydou ses locaux pendant à la
fois des campagnes pour des annonceurs
nationaux des annonceurs locaux pour lui
demander des commerces de proximité de
la ville de plaisir mais aussi pour la
coller les collectivités qui dit pour
les gamins ils peuvent communiquer sur
nos dispositifs et c représentent
quasiment 20% de notre préparation
[Musique]
non
oh
faux
[Musique]
pop
on se remémore le mois de mars 2020 ça a
été immédiat total en l'espace de quinze
jours tout s'est arrêté et il a fallu
trouver des solutions donc pour les
collaborateurs ça tout de suite était la
mise en place du chômage partiel et ça
c'est quelque chose qui a bien
fonctionné dans notre domaine d'activité
et ensuite on a cherché les solutions
vous dire c'est pas possible que l'on
reste sans rien faire del arte le retour
du confinement au mois de mai 2000 va on
a eu l'idée de monter ici vous envoyer
encore les restes ici d'un studio d'un
studio digital on s'est dit notre
matériel et l'aïd or les clients ont
besoin de communiquer on va tenter
quelque chose on va tenter de faire
venir ici à elancourt dans notre dépôt
on a créé on a tout le matériel sur
place on s'est dit bon on ne peut pas
louer aussi cher que si on était en
événements donc proposer à nos clients
de venir communiquer à travers l'outil
qu'on connaît tous cependant le
confinement et pendant ces deux années
qui est la visioconférence ou le
streaming et on a créé des événements
digitaux vous avez chiffré la perte que
vous avez sans doute c'est très simple
c'est un bilan par le chiffre d'affaires
c'est moins 50% de chiffre d'affaires
par an et là avec cette reprise
d'activité comment vous la vivez cette
reprise d'activité alors elle est un
petit peu elle se ressent un petit peu
comme l'arrêt elle est aussi brutal qui
a été l'arrêt c'est à dire que les
clients se sont cherchés les annonceurs
qui sont les agences qui sont nos
clients principaux mettre du temps à se
décider et d'un seul coup on sent qu'il
ya une volonté en ce moment de 20 de se
réunir parce que tout ce qui est
sanitaire était un petit peu allégés on
a le droit de se réunir à nouveau on a
le droit de refaire des salons donc ça
donne un petit peu un élan à tout ceci
malheureusement c'est sur les chapeaux
de roue s'est tout de suite hold up
[Musique]
on a passé deux ans extrêmement
difficile avec cette crise sanitaire on
a essayé de jouer notre rôle à travers
la crise puisque on a mis nos cabines à
disposition des soignants et ça c'était
par contre une vraie expérience
maintenant je vous cache pas que on est
heureux d'être là aujourd'hui parce que
parce que financièrement ça a été très
difficile on savait que on nous a
indirectement interdit travail et donc
pour une startup c'était compliqué
j'étais obligé de reprendre un travail
voilà donc c'est d'autant plus difficile
c'est qu'il faut travailler dans
l'entreprise plus essayer de de relever
cette start-up parce qu'on peut pas
abandonner c'est un projet qui est
vraiment qu'ils étaient tellement
d'impact et qui marche tellement bien
que l'on peut pas s'arrêter là vous êtes
un entrepreneur un des entrepreneurs
français qui avait été passe finalement
alors comme beaucoup malheureusement
mais il faut savoir que 80 % des
startups françaises ont été impactés par
par la crise malheureusement il ya
encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de startups
qui sont en train de déposer le bilan gd
propres collègues qui ont investi cinq
ans de leur vie parfois deux cent mille
euros de leur poche et qui sont en train
de tout perdre donc c'est une vraie
difficulté vous êtes présent aujourd'hui
au thé qui nomme c'est la relance c'est
la reprise d'activité ça y est alors la
reprise je dirais pas que c'est la
reprise mais en tout cas déjà ça nous
fait du bien de repartir dans ce projet
c'est presque ému de vous dire ça mais
oui
ç'a failli s'arrêter disons oui
c'était extrêmement difficile et savez
c'est des gens ne comprennent pas en
fait les start up il pense que une start
up c'est des gens à qui bricolent dans
leur jardin ce qui est pas faux à la
base j'ai souvent ce sont des ingénieurs
sont des férus de technologie mais il
oublie une chose c'est que ce sont avant
tout aussi des investisseurs on met
beaucoup de temps mais on aussi beaucoup
d'argent mois ses trente ans de ma vie
c'est 30 ans d'économies de ma vie de de
carrière que j'ai mis là-dedans
financièrement
[Musique]
on a choisi le modèle de l'alternance
pour pour deux raisons la première c'est
que nous ne souhaitions pas qu'ils aient
de barrières financières à l'entrée ont
souhaité répondre à un besoin urgent de
compétences des entreprises
[Musique]
toutes les entreprises aujourd'hui
quelle que soit la taille des
entreprises puisque une tpe
malheureusement des tpe se font aussi
attaqué et c'est dramatique ou des pme
pour lesquelles c'est dramatique aussi
jusqu'aux grands groupes effectivement
tous secteurs confondus on va former des
experts en cybersécurité c'est à dire
des gens qui vont à la fois comprendre
les besoins de production de l'industrie
mais avec ce souci de caisse que
potentiellement peut mal se passer et
être exploitées à des fins malveillantes
[Musique]
et chaque jour nous livrons près de 5000
commandes de pièces détachées
électroménager à destination des
consommateurs des à des particuliers
pour leur permettre justement de réparer
leur lave linge leurs fours leur frigo
leur micron l'heure à leur aspirateur
c'est une
sociétés que j'ai fondées donc il ya
treize ans maintenant après avoir
travaillé une dizaine d'années chez
l'article leader de l'électroménager en
france et je me c'est d'abord dans la
centrale d'achat accessoires et pièces
détachées c'est clairement la main que
j'ai identifié un besoin suffisamment
satisfaits pour tous les consommateurs
dans toutes les enseignes d'ailleurs
arriver à trouver une pièce détachée ou
un accessoire pour entretenir ou réparer
son appareil électroménager et à
l'époque je me suis dit ce ne sont que
des produits de besançon ne sont que des
produits de contraintes il ya peu de
plaisir à aller chercher en magasin donc
le canal internet est un canal
fantastique pour distribuer il répondre
à ces besoins consommateurs donc c'est
partant de cette expérience que j'ai
dessiné décidé de franchir le pas de
l'entrepreneuriat et que j'ai lancé à
sauver sa saison
[Musique]
c'est l'un des points stratégiques pour
le groupe safran basculer vers l'avion
vert pour cela safran va investir 4
milliards d'euros entre 2021 et 2025
trois quarts de cet hermétisme ans va
être accordée à la décarbonation de
l'avion pour en parler nous sommes avec
le directeur de s'affrontaient que
vincent garnier bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors s'affrontaient qu'est ce que c'est
alors ça frontex et le centre de
recherche mutualisé du groupe safran
nous travaillons au sein du centre de
recherche sur un certain nombre de
thématiques transverses à l'ensemble des
sociétés du groupe safran et l'objectif
est de travailler sur les nouvelles
technologies qui vont précisément être
intégré dans l'avion vers à l'horizon de
2035 le centre de recherche là dedans
est un élément clé qu'est ce qu'on va
trouver un avion vers qu'est-ce que
safran va pouvoir y apporter d'abord un
moteur beaucoup plus performants que les
moteurs même ceux qui viennent d'entrer
en service vous savez peut-être safran a
fait rentrer en service récemment un
nouveau moteur qui fait un gain de
carburant de 15% par rapport aux avions
qui volent en majorité dans la flotte
actuelle et nous prévoyons d'ici 2035 de
faire entrer en service un nouveau type
de moteur et ce nouveau type de moteur
nous préparons de commençons de préparer
dès aujourd'hui ça fait l'objet d'un
programme de recherche et technologie
que nous avons annoncés ici même à
magny-les-hameaux il ya un peu plus d'un
an maintenant le directeur général du
groupe l'a fait lui-même ou pour vous
dire l'importance que ce programme revêt
pour le groupe et donc c'est le premier
élément vraiment de l'avion vers vue de
sa france et ce moteur qui va faire
bénéficier l'avion qu'il portera de 20 %
de gain de consommation supplémentaire
par rapport à la référence déjà
extrêmement performante qui est le
moteur leap on va travailler également
dans l'avion vers sur le fait d'aller
j'ai tous les équipements et là c'est
vraiment des thématiques de type
matériaux beaucoup plus performant
beaucoup plus robuste beaucoup plus
léger qui vont permettre à l'ensemble
des équipements du groupe d'être ré
redimensionner vraiment réexaminée dans
leur au plus profond d'eux-mêmes pour
pouvoir faire alléger l'avion qui va les
porter l'autre pilier de cette
transformation c'est la mise à
disposition carburant à d'aviation
durable et donc le nous dans le cadre de
la vie en vert nous travaillons ce que
toutes les technologies que nous
proposons puisse être compatible avec
ces carburants durables je suis
christophe vergne le fondateur et
président de michael
liles coop une autre activité et dans la
e-santé ce qu'on appelle la santé
numérique
[Musique]
nous travaillons sur une aide aux
professionnels de santé en oncologie
notamment dans leur prise de décision
il faut savoir que les professionnels
ont aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
donner d'informations à gérer et donc le
métier rendu plus difficile à la fois
donc pour une meilleure prise en charge
des patients mais également pour la
recherche clinique ou encore des
développements une intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]
nous avons développé à ce jour trois
outils le premier outil développé par
maicon est un tableau de bord pour les
rcp et ce tableau de bord permet de
visualiser les informations toutes les
informations critiques pertinentes
sur un patient donné qui va être
discutée dans le cadre de ces de ces
réunions un deuxième qui consiste à qui
est une interface patients qui consiste
à capter les symptômes du patient qui
est en traitement et un troisième en
fait qui est une interface pour
l'infirmière de pratique avant ces cas
là on va dire sorte de monitoring
d'outils de monitoring du patient avec à
la fois le plan thérapeutique qui a été
choisi et la remontée des symptômes de
ces patients
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec nous le créateur de day by day
maurepas grand marché vrac laurent
seigne bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
c'est le deuxième magasin de ce format
là il ya 75 des bd en france mais ce
sont des magasins de centre-ville
épicerie droguerie hygiène les clients
ressortait des débats et des en disant
c'est génial on peut pas faire tout nos
courses puisqu'il n'a pas les produits
frais donc on a été un peu plus loin et
le concept des vallées grand marché vrac
y va c'est un débat idées de centre
ville et qu'on installe en périphérie et
sur lequel on va ajouter tous les
produits frais avec des commerçants
engagé locaux qui m'ont rejoint dans le
projet pour défendre les mêmes valeurs
que celles que je voulais porter avec
des vagues alors justement on est passé
un le fromage et le boucher le maraîcher
alors c'est qui qui sont toutes ces
personnes je suis vraiment super fier
d'avoir réussi à convaincre ces gens qui
m'ont accompagné je vais commencer par
le boucher donc la boucherie cardié
c'était vraiment un message à envoyer
aux mort passe bien aussi de dire que la
proximité et la périphérie pouvait être
complémentaires donc la boucherie cardié
c'est une boucherie du centre ville de
maurepas et qui a rejoint le projet en
plus de son activité ensuite on a
derrière vous ludovic biseau meilleur
ouvrier de france qui a une activité à
rambouillet et qui m'a fait l'honneur de
me rejoindre dans le projet et ensuite
alors pour ludovic un petit moment le
les les produits c'est le terroir donc
c'est vraiment la volonté de proposer
une gamme qui correspond à chaque
terroir
[Musique]
je m'appelle marie pierre sirinelli je
suis responsable d'agencé bâtiment
durable chez cytale sita et c'est un peu
moins de soixante personnes qui tous les
jours cherchent à réduire l'empreinte
environnementale du bâtiment
[Musique]
je suis dominique renard brazy j'ai
fondé à plier en 2019 à fleyriat c'est
une une entreprise hébergés à skis cuba
l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines et la mission daf les ja c'est
de simplifier le passage à l'économie
circulaire dans le bâtiment
[Musique]
la rencontre avec la fia c'est un réseau
commun entre notre direction et
dominique blazy le partenariat s'est
fait assez simplement par par la
proximité puisque btp consultant sita et
btp diagnostics sont situés à saint
quentin comme comme à fria on a eu un
besoin qui est de développer un outil
pour une facilité
pour nous faciliter la vie dans le
travail du quotidien dans la réalisation
de diagnostics bmd produits équipements
matériaux déchets
sita et et l'utilisateur de da kibo
l'assistant digitale du diagnostic le
diagnostiqueur va sur un sur un chantier
qui qui a pour but d'être des construit
en partie ou en totalité
et va pouvoir quantifier
la matière sortante a qui bossent c'est
un outil digital qui permet de
construire facilement les scénarios de
valorisation des déchets sur des
chantiers de démolition et de
déconstruction
bonjour bienvenue chez nouvel échange je
m'appelle sophie keller je suive co
fondatrice de l'entreprise avec mon
associé coralie mon baluchon c'est quoi
c'est ainsi des commerces de proximité
de vente de produits vrac alimentaire et
non alimentaire français bio locaux et
zéro déchet
[Musique]
mon baluchon a été créée donc en mars
2022 on a débuté notre activité le 29
avril dernier voilà le site a ouvert à
ce moment là les gens commandent sur
notre site en ligne voilà les produits
et leurs contenants puisqu'on a
plusieurs types de contenants des bocaux
des recherches kraft biodégradable mais
aussi des bouteilles consignées voilà il
ya ensuite ils choisissent leurs modes
de livraison donc livraison à domicile
sur le lieu de travail ou en retrait
click and collect et bien du coup ce
matin on va livrer donc sur un lieu de
travail à domicile et on va aussi
recevoir potentiellement une cliente en
retrait en click and collect
[Musique]
quand un client commande sur internet la
commande tombe sur notre back office on
la voit apparaître on regarde le jour de
la livraison ou du clic qu'elles
collectent et on prépare sa commande au
plus tôt la bei
[Musique]
dieu
madame
alors je vous lis moi votre deuxième
commande je crois c'est que la première
vous a plu exactement vrai nom c'était
top donc j'ai préféré les jeux j'ai
commandé
[Musique]
le chantier a débuté en juin 2010 9 le
bâtiment maths il a été conçu par le
promoteur immobilier codic avec comme
locataire le groupe orange
en fait sur cet immeuble
des équipes quatre immeubles différents
avec des équipes des directions
techniques du réseau orange c'est
l'occasion à la fois de regrouper des
équipes qui étaient éclatées par le
passé sur plusieurs sites plusieurs
sites différents donc de les regrouper
et de créer un vrai esprit de cohésion
en ayant un peu moins de 1000 personnes
on est autour de 850 personnes qui vont
de salariés qui vont rejoindre cet email
et
native c'est un projet d'abord qui
remplace un immeuble existant qui les
gens s'en souviennent peut-être été
l'immeuble de la poste sur cinq mètres
carrés avec de vieilles tuiles blanche
assez extraordinaire qu'au immeuble il
nous avons pu retravailler un immeuble
de 18 mètres carrés où nous avons eu la
chance de pouvoir rassembler tous les
services d'orange pour en faire vraiment
leur quartier des affaires
[Musique]